okay so since you've been in la michael
since was at the beginning of february
yeah i got out here the first was my
first full day
and how much of that has been business
and how much of that has been vacation
um probably about
half an hour well it's i've wanted it
all to be business but i've had more off
days than i would have liked you know
probably about half and half
um between putting myself on tape and
auditions and stuff on some days and
then
other days i've gone to venice beach and
hung out with friends you know so it's
been a good mix
and since you have been doing some
taping why not tape from new york and
just have it on
youtube or vimeo and send it to a
casting director um
that yeah i totally could do that the
reason
a couple reasons for coming out instead
of just staying in new york and taping
one it's been this thing i've built up
in my head that i've wanted to do
so that that's why that was the number
one reason for coming out
the other stuff is you can put on tape
easily
for um a new pilot but if they're
casting
a guest star role or a day player or
something
you kind of got to be here to book that
so i was just figuring
why not come out and try and get some of
those appointments as well rather than
just stay in new york you know um
but uh yeah i mean i could that's
probably my plan for next year will be
to
put on tape for new york and come out
should i get
a big audition that's worth it come out
and then stay from there you know
oh so you're planning another trip
yeah i'm i'm thinking probably coming
back next pilot season i learned
a lot about the experience now maybe
what timing might be better
for someone in my level you know
not anywhere near a name but having a
couple credits you know
um i've heard it might be better a
little later in the pilot season for me
so i might try that next year
just how the rolls are being cast you
know they cast star names first and then
it goes to the
uh reoccurring and then the guest star
so oh okay
yeah so i might try a little later next
year but definitely i definitely want to
come back
it's a nice time of the year to get out
of new york so
yeah well so what would you recommend to
another actor
um that's you say at your level yeah
what would you recommend like suppose
they said you know i'm thinking of doing
the same thing
i mean i i would say try it for sure
as far as timing goes i was talking to
my manager about it and they said the
seasons run
a little differently every year last
year i guess it was
faster so they thought it was going to
be a fast season this year
but i would say for me
i'm going to try a little later this
year only be next year
only because that's what i have heard
from
industry friends who have done it before
me so
i don't feel like i have uh
all that much experience with it to
impart to someone
but that was the knowledge i got was a
little later
because right now you'll only be
competing for
roles that are going like for me roles
that will be going to josh gad and
people who you know
uh people who already have names that
are character men you know
okay so if i came i heard a little later
maybe uh it would be more of the small
not smaller roles but
you know roles that aren't cast
contingent on a name